survives in Argentina by picking up
plastic and cardboard to recycle he
lives in the province of Buenos Aires
an eval also receives around 100 of
government assistance every month
the money is worth nothing we can barely
buy something to eat you can only eat
chicken because beef is a luxury
argentines are struggling with an
inflation rate of around 8 percent every
month
the rising prices are not only hurting
the poor Paola Casillas Works in sales
and her husband is a retired police
officer they support five children they
used to be able to afford a private
school but not anymore we had to cut our
expenses I didn't complain about the new
school we even got some of the books but
we are trying to adapt to the process
all the time it's a difficult situation
for all of us
but inflation has not only affected
their children's access to an education
inflation has become a serious problem
for families in Argentina and they have
to be creative to make ends meet the
price of sugar for example has gone up
around 140 percent in the past year the
price of milk for example over 100
percent
this is a working class family in
Argentina they say they can no longer
afford to cover their most basic needs
[Music]
outside their home paola's father-in-law
is building a room for a family member
who cannot afford A Home of Their Own
these are life stories of how people
cope with price increases every month in
a country where the economy is in the
red
shortage of foreign currency worsened by
the worst drought in decades exchange
rate controls and the government's
inability to control the ongoing
situation
half of the population receives
government assistance
cash handouts are crucial there aren't
many countries that have the Social
Security level Argentina has but the
country has serious economic troubles
the cash handouts help that they're not
a solution
most economists agree that Argentina
urgently needs a plan to stabilize the
economy but presidential elections are
four months away and that's why any
serious economic reforms ironhold
there is